أنت شخص لديه مسيرة طويلة
في الجيش السوداني كنت
المفتش العام والآن تجد
نفسك على رأس انقلاب ، لماذا
ما دفعك لتكون جزءًا من هذا
أعرف ، استمع ماكاروفا تان تان لديه
إلين ما أنا  يعني وعندما
يريدك الجمهور أن
تذهب ، ستذهب: ماذا عن المتظاهرين
أنفسهم هل تسمح لهم
بمواصلة احتلال المساحة
التي يشغلونها أمام
المقر العسكري ، لا لا لا
فيتالي ، فلنتحدث قليلاً  حول
علاقتك بالولايات المتحدة ،
جاء وفد أمريكي للتو لرؤيتك
والتحدث معك ، ما هي أهم
أولوياتك عندما
يتعلق الأمر بعلاقتك مع حيوان الولايات المتحدة ،
فنحن نفضل عمي في قانوننا ، لذا فقد
صممنا متجر خياط في بعض naan unna  هي
معجزة كيبايا و سوبناوتيكا المسيح التي
تطورت ونحن نعلم أن هناك عملية بدأت
في محاكمة الرئيس السابق عمر
البشير بسبب سوء التصرف المالي و
لكن بالطبع هناك
استدعاءات أكبر  إضافات ومخاوف أكبر على
سبيل المثال الجرائم التي ارتكبت
في مقتل المتظاهرين ،
ما الذي ستفعله للتأكد من
أنه يواجه العدالة في تلك العطلة
ناتاليا كان ذلك هنا د.
أنتلي أفعل ، تتوقع أنه
سيواجه تهم بارتكاب جرائم ضد
الإنسانية بسبب ما حدث في ذلك الحصن
هنا في السودان ،
ماذا عن زعيم يحدث هناك
، لقد أتيت إلى هنا ما
ستكون رسالتك إلى العالم ماذا
هل تطلب من العالم أن يفعل من أجل السودان ،
نعم جميل ، والخلية السفلية يجب أن
تحدد مارتيني محمد علي
مارتيني أو أن تقرأ وتنقل الأريكة